alors c'est la deuxième fois sur cette
chaîne que je réagis à l'actualité car
quelque chose de vraiment important se
passe
la première fois c'était le côté de 19
en mars et s'était en effet quelque
chose de bien plus important que ce
qu'on pouvait croire à ce moment là et
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'une
actualité qui me semble bien plus
importante encore que locaux vides 19 on
va parler du licenciement de la docteure
timide que brooke codirectrice de
l'équipe des tic désir de google est
chercheuse académique de renom son
licenciement a eu lieu mercredi soir en
californie jeudi matin en france
alors il ya encore énormément de flou
dans cette histoire en grande partie car
chaque plante essaient de se protéger
sur le plan de légal mais le tld air de
ma compréhension des choses on laquelle
j'ai une énorme crédence c'est que la
direction de google à censurer nos
publications de son équipe t tic désir
et ça c'est quelque chose de très
inquiétant car comme j'en ai déjà
beaucoup parler dans cette chaîne
et comme on en parle beaucoup plus longs
mois encore dans notre livre le fab le
chantier il semble devenu urgent de
réfléchir à l'éthique des algorithmes de
google et des autres entreprises de la
tête vers ceux ci sont utilisées
quotidiennement par des milliards
d'humains sur terre et influences
quotidiennement l'information à laquelle
des milliards du mans sont exposés mais
il y a une bonne nouvelle dans cette
histoire et même une excellente nouvelle
suite au licenciement de steam ne
brouillent les employés de google ont
écrit une lettre ouverte collective
protestants ce licenciement est
exigeante trois choses de leur direction
à savoir un plus d'explications sur la
censure de publication de plus de
transparence vis-à-vis du grand public
en particulier vous et moi et 3 un
engagement univoque de la direction pour
plus d'intégrité de recherche et de
liberté académique et pour le respect
des principes de philosophie de la
recherche chez google et des principes
de google autour désir au moment où je
filme cette vidéo la lettre a été signée
par un total de 1600 4 employés de
google est de 2500 12-0 individus du
monde académique de l'industrie et de la
société civile
et parmi eux il ya moi alors 1604 c'est
beaucoup mais google c'est presque cent
mille employés et donc ça reste en fait
une petite fraction seulement des
employés quant à 2512 c'est presque
décevant
ce que j'aimerais c'est que ces nombres
aille au moins au delà des dix mille
donc si je fais cette vidéo c'est
surtout pour essayer de convaincre
davantage de gens parmi vous d'apporter
à votre tour votre support à la
ouverte non seulement pour supporter
timide que brou le licenciement a eu
lieu dans des conditions très étrange
notamment de la vie de son propre
supérieur qui l'a découvert après coup
mais aussi et surtout pour supporter la
recherche et la discussion sur l'éthique
des algorithmes non seulement chez
google mais aussi dans d'autres
entreprises et dans le monde académique
et même au delà
oui car cette lettre n'est pas une
réaction à un simple fait divers
c'est une réaction à une censure de la
recherche sur les tic des algorithmes
les plus sophistiqués et les plus
influents au monde
aujourd'hui google search répond à des
milliards de requêtes par jour et
l'algorithme de recommandations de
youtube et responsables de 70% des
milliards de visionnages de vidéos sur
la plateforme quotidiennement
autrement dit deux fois sur trois quand
un individu regarde une vidéo
c'est parce que l'algorithme le lui a
recommandé or de nombreuses recherches
montrent que l'impact de cet algorithme
a longtemps été catastrophique avec des
théories du complot qui font des
millions voire des milliards de vues
cumulé des vidéos qui nie le changement
climatique qui font presque autant de
vue que celle qui l'expliquent et des
contenus qu'ils propagent de la
mésinformation dangereuse pour la santé
publique
al'inverse les vues des vidéos de grande
qualité pourrait être démultipliée
si google souhaitait davantage
promouvoir l'information fiable et
récemment il ya eu de nombreux progrès
comme le recrutement de timides que brou
en 2018 l'investissement dans les
équipes des tic d irak elle a monté les
nombreuses publications académiques de
cette équipe ou même la prestigieuse
conférence fairness canta bility
transparency que timide que hbo a aidé à
créer et qui est organisé par l'acm une
association internationale de la
recherche en informatique notamment dans
le monde académique mais plus
généralement tous ces signaux ont
certainement aidé à instaurer une
culture au sein de google qui
sensibilise les chercheurs et les
ingénieurs au risque de leurs
algorithmes et qui met sous pression la
direction de google comme ce fut le cas
lors du refus des ingénieurs d'une
collaboration avec l'armée américaine
dans une certaine mesure ces progrès
éthique ont été validées par l'ajout de
bagnères lors de la crise du comité 19
qui redirige vers wikipedia ou vers le
site de l'om s ou par l'audit externe de
guillaume chasse le haut alors certes
selon guillaume chazot où selon moi même
ces progrès sont encore très largement
insuffisant mais au moins il ya un net
progrès avec notamment des
collaborations avec des académiques
externe
étudier les impacts sociaux des
algorithmes de google comme dans le cas
de la fameuse publication de timminco
proulx et de ses collègues qui semble
avoir été accepté dans un premier temps
par la direction de google
cependant le licenciement de timides que
brou entame sérieusement cette culture
de responsabilité éthique ils en voient
surtout un signal important à tout
employé de google de questionner
panneaux produits où vous serez virés
il est critique qu'il y ait une réponse
proportionnée à ce signal détectable à
mon sens pour l'instant la réponse est
superbe mais elle n'est pas encore
proportionnée pour qu'elle le devienne
il est critique que cette lettre ouverte
est beaucoup plus de soutien de beaucoup
plus de monde à la fois à l'intérieur de
google et à l'extérieur
c'est notre occasion de dire à google
que les préoccupations autour de leurs
algorithmes ne peuvent pas être caché
sous le tapis d'exiger plus de
transparence de leur part et surtout de
valoriser beaucoup plus la dimension
sécurité et éthique de ces algorithmes
sachant l'influencé qu'ont aujourd'hui
ses algorithmes de google et les
préoccupations à avoir sur la qualité
des informations diffusées sur internet
ceci me semble critique pour le futur de
l'humanité
d'autant que le signal à envoyer ne se
limite en fait absolument pas à google
c'est aussi l'occasion de dire aux
directions des autres entreprises
facebook twitter amazon microsoft ou
apple que l'éthique de leur algorithme
doit être prise très au sérieux et que
toute préoccupation soulevée en interne
ou en externe doit être traité avec soin
et respect c'est aussi l'occasion de
dire à tous les chercheurs en
informatique que l'amélioration des
performances des algorithmes qui
conçoivent ne devrait pas être leur
préoccupation première
aujourd'hui encore il est beaucoup plus
cool et valoriser de découvrir un nouvel
algorithme qui résout ou tel problème
plus rapidement que les algorithmes
précédent ou de montrer qu'une nouvelle
implémentation permet d'améliorer les
performances seront tels métriques d'un
facteur 1,5 que de soulever ou de
résoudre tel ou tel problème de sécurité
ou des tic avec tel ou tel déploiement
de tels ou tels algorithmes aujourd'hui
encore ces articles sur la sécurité ou
sur les tic sont plus facilement rejeté
et les chercheurs qui s'investissent
dans ces voies de recherche vont donc
avoir moins d'opportunités pour rester
dans le monde académique et continuer ce
genre de recherche
plus généralement on ne valorisant pas
suffisamment l'éthique et la sécurité
dans le monde académique
nous donnons ainsi de très mauvaises
incentive à la recherche publique
enfin cette lettre est l'occasion de
dire où chercheurs des autres
disciplines que s'ils font eux mêmes de
la recherche sur les enjeux éthiques des
algorithmes ou sur les réseaux sociaux
ils seront écoutés et non pas ignorer ou
poursuivis par des organisations comme
google en particulier il me semble
critique que la recherche éthique se
fasse à la fois par des chercheurs de
google qui analyse les algorithmes et
les données que seul google possède
ils sont difficiles à partager pour des
raisons de privacy mais aussi et surtout
à l'extérieur de google ou la liberté
académique permettra de critiquer les
annonces de google et de ses chercheurs
et d'éviter ainsi en éthique soit chine
malheureusement très courant rendre les
algorithmes robustement bénéfique est un
fabuleux chantier mais pour l'initier il
est urgent de montrer qu'il nous tient à
coeur
et la meilleure façon de se faire
aujourd'hui c'est sans doute de signer
la lettre ouverte dont le lien est en
descriptions